herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen
Ausgabe von Homeshopping mit mir Gernot
Paradeiser und meinem Kollegen mein Name
ist Graz
heute haben wir ein wunderbares Produkt
für Sie ich glaube alle Fahrradfahrer
kennen das Gefühl sie fahren in der Früh
in die Arbeit und es friert sie am
Sack
und genau hierfür haben wir ein tolles
Produkt einen beheizbaren Fahrradsattel
meine Damen und Herren
beheizbar ein beheizbarer Sattel toll
beheizbar ja sage ich doch beheizbar
nein beheizbar egal auf jeden Fall
dieser Sattel erzeugt eine
Kerntemperatur von ca 50 Grad verfügt
über sechs heizzüglingen und so dürfte
ihnen nie zwischen den Beinen kalt
werden maximal ausprobieren
ich kann es nicht glauben hab ich liebte
den einfach mal von hinten durch und du
lässt dich einfach einmal fallen als
würdest du jetzt da auf dem Fahrrad
sitzen sitzt du gut ich schalte dich ein
so und jetzt müssen die Eichen langsam
warm werden es ist jetzt noch keine 50
Grad du kannst jetzt entscheiden ob du
welche mittlere oder harte Eier willst
jetzt haben ein Problem jetzt muss ich
kurz zurücksprachen
jetzt höre ich gerade von der Regime wir
haben einen kleinen Kurzschluss das Ding
hat auf 150 Grad
mein lieber Kreuz er ist sowieso in
einem Alter wo ich glaube der
Kinderwunsch
eher vernachlässigt werden kann meine
Damen und Herren kaufen Sie dieses
wunderbare Produkt jetzt wenn sie sich
auch immer über kalte einen also über
kalte
ärgern auf dem Weg in die Arbeit mein
lieber Kreuz ich
auf wiederschauen
[Musik]
weißt du auch immer seine Scheißdreck
aus dem Internet